there are two styles of communication
violent and non-violent and a whole
spectrum in between
violent communication is coercive
manipulative and it hurts it includes
making generalizations and a use of
language that induces fear shame or
guilt it is often ineffective since it
diverts our attention away from
clarifying our actual needs and
distracts us from solving the actual
conflict
non-violent communication is based on
the idea that we all share universal
human desires such as the need for trust
safety and appreciation it allows us to
empathize and think clearly
and as a result reach a better and more
honest understanding of each other
[Music]
non-violent communication follows four
steps
observation
feeling
needs and requests
to understand how it works let's imagine
a college student being late for class
old jay her former teacher would usually
have just said and here she comes again
lay dan in class he would then give her
a hard time and after as his form of
punishment a bunch of senseless
assignments
then both would feel bad for the rest of
the day
nuj who's her current teacher learned
about non-violent communication and
knows that it begins with a clear
observation
during observation he tries noticing
concrete facts things that happen at
that very moment new jay jots down that
anne arrived 20 minutes late and that
his pulse is up
possibly a sign of stress
when focusing on his feelings new j
connects with his heart and can learn to
understand various underlying emotions
this is important because what seems to
be anger might in fact be sadness during
this step it is essential to distinguish
feelings from thoughts
after class new jay shares his
observation and explains to anne that he
feels disrespected when someone is late
for his class
knowing his needs is important because
it allows him to enrich his life and
feel at peace if we disregard our needs
or don't live up to our values we
experience stress and frustration
understanding that we all have universal
human needs is perhaps the most
important step in the process
new j tells anne that they should find a
way to respect each other's values and
desires
lastly there is the request which
clarifies what future nuj wants for
himself and this relationship clear
requests are hence crucial to a
transformative communication
when we ask for concrete actions we
often find creative ways to ensure that
everyone's needs are met
new jay asks anne not to come to class
at all if she happens to run later than
one minute
[Music]
marshall rosenberg who developed the
model liked to show the differences
between the communication styles with
two animals the jackal was a symbol of
aggression dominance and violent
communication
the giraffe with his long neck and big
heart represents a clear-sighted and
compassionate speaker and non-violent
communication style
all violence rosenberg wrote is the
result of people tricking themselves
into believing that their pain derives
from other people and that consequently
those people deserve to be punished
what are your thoughts on this model
share your thoughts in the comments
below and check the description for more
details and interesting links about the
topic
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's
patreon.com slash sprouts